here we go
wow even my jacket changed that truly is
a real
full moon happy october folks you know
what that means it's halloween
month not day not weekend month this is
just a bit of an update for october you
know how that stuff goes i like keeping
in touch with you and long story short
we're going to have fun this month a
horror movie month the horror movie
marathon i figure i might as well do a
lot of videos this month now that you've
seen my true form
i mean every video this month is gonna
be horror movie and i don't mean you
know sprinkled within the week
monday horror movie review tuesday
horror movie review wednesday
thursday maybe friday i need to see how
much i need to rest oh my god these
hands look so bad on film they look like
nightmare at 20 000 feet
point is on the weekdays horror movie
reviews
weekends i rest and it's all horror
movie i don't care what trailers come
out if there's a new trailer
to one division we'll save that until
november
one division comes out in november so i
guess i'll just talk about the thing
when it comes out then
the show it's all horror movies this
october and a lot of them
say for a couple of exceptions i'm
already invested in the boys so
gonna do the boys going to finish up the
boys got a boys video coming this
weekend and the next weekend's the
finale of the season
then it's done so i guess i'll do those
videos on the weekends my weekends of
rest so it doesn't actually
coincide with the horror movie it's not
taking up the horror movie time i think
we found a loophole my friends
also will i imagine i can just call it
the great horror movie gushing because
obviously they're going to be movies
that i
like or at least remember liking there's
already one that i watch i was like this
movie's fun
it has good energy i'm gonna wow that
did not hold up so there's gonna be at
least one that i bag on maybe there will
be others so i have them all
lined up you know i have my blue rays
there and them all
mapped out they're literally on the
floor representing the days of the week
point is if i'm given the choice i'm
gonna watch and review movies as i like
you know always i'm gonna have fun with
the horror movies that's the fun of
horror movies they can be cheesy
but still fun some i haven't reviewed
yet some
might be re-reviews because i kind of
want to revisit a couple movies see if
they still hold up maybe i did a video
on them
eons ago mindsets change opinions change
i just i like revisiting things like
that a couple of the movies i have on
the short list are not necessarily
horror but they do have that
halloween flavor to it haven't done
videos on them yet so
maybe i want to do videos on those some
unconventional maybe you think oh he's
totally going to talk about this
maybe i'm not but these are more or less
horror movies that i
enjoy or at least remember enjoying
maybe they don't hold up as much
you get to peer into my soul so the
month of october horror movie
extravaganza i just wanted to tell you
what kind of fun we're going to have
this month i'm a fan of horror movies if
you're a fan of horror movies
enjoy the month of october on my channel
that's what i'm here for is what you're
here for we're here to have fun so
october should be really fun starting on
monday
you know but from monday till the end
you are not prepared all right so what
are your favorite horror movies what are
the horror movies that might be obscure
that you're like you know what
i like children of the corn three i like
leprechaun in space
whatever your favorites are whatever you
want to see me talk about comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you